[Musica]
che bello essere qui veramente mai avrei
pensato in vita mia di ricevere un
invito come relatore ad un test tanto
meno al primo da tex education d'italia
la colpa di questa cosa e di michele
genera che abbiamo invitato e per questo
motivo insomma volevo ringraziare valori
grazie a loro e chiedere permesso per
poter chiudere la batteria degli
interventi
non prima però di aver ringraziato tutti
i relatori che mi hanno preceduto ed
emozionato ma in primis ringraziare
tutti gli organizzatori ragazze e
ragazzi impagabili che da mesi stanno
sbattendo per portare sui piedi un telex
di questa portata e ci hanno consentito
di riflettere sull'importanza del mondo
scolastico dei propri modelli educativi
anche per mia voce che sempre sempre
devono porre al centro le nuove
generazioni devono farlo però tenendo
bene a mente che insidia adesso stanno
nascondendo in questa in questa società
sono insidie che sono un po risentono di
questi cambiamenti cambiamenti epocali
che stiamo assistendo che devono tenere
conto necessariamente di tutte le
esigenze urlate a gran voce dalle nuove
generazioni che io sento il riscontro
sento che c'è un grandissimo scollamento
da rispetto a quelli che sono i fermenti
e intellettivi creativi e motivi delle
nuove generazioni e la capacità
d'ascolto e di comprenderli da parte di
quelle che sono un po chiamiamo nelle
generazioni al comando è una cosa che io
non nascondiamocelo ce ne stiamo
accorgendo un po tutti e quindi tutti
siamo chiamati a fare la nostra la
nostra parte una parte che
necessariamente dovremmo recitare in
chiave di sviluppo sostenibile ed avendo
bene a mano il copione della
responsabilità sociale familiare da dire
insomma oggi siamo proprio nel posto
giusto da questo punto di vista quindi
grazie come ho sentito che hanno scritto
gli organizzatori stessi organizzare un
telex significa ripartire con il piede
giusto e dare l'idea ai giovani tutto il
mondo a partire da rieti che oggi non è
stato il centro italia oggi ho sentito
rieti come il centro il centro del mondo
è una città piena di arte di cultura di
storia e di spiritualità
dare l'idea quindi che questo
cambiamento è concreto
è un cambiamento veramente possibile
quindi mi avete sentito citare le nuove
generazioni
queste nuove generazioni è un concetto
un po così astratta del quale un po
tutti ci riempiamo spesso la bocca senza
mai andare a capire bene come
identificarle come riconoscerle come
entrare in contatto con loro
ora vi dico con una certa presunzione
che io forse una chiave di accesso sulle
nuove generazioni ce l'avrei anche e vi
dico addirittura che passa dal crocevia
della potrebbe passare dal crocevia
dell'istruzione pubblica scolastica
prima di addentrarmi vorrei intanto
presentarvela presentandone le
generalità di nome fa in sports and see
di cognome videogiochi elettronici
competitivi anche po per giustificare
perché sia qui o a parlarne volevo un po
portarvi dentro a quella che la sua
definizione canonica ma giusto per
andare ad informarvi di quelle che sono
le sue sfaccettature sfaccettature di
questo mondo che certo non possono
essere semplificate da una definizione
esistono moltissime tipologie di sport
questa definizione diciamo riassume una
panorama veramente variegato e complesso
così come complesse sono le molte
discipline che sono competitive che
variano in base ai trend del momento
salvo alcuni titoli che diciamo sono dei
cult è ormai da decenni
volevo farvi un esempio appunto di
quelli che sono i titoli un po che
dicevo prima variano in base ai trend
vi faccio l'esempio della disciplina
degli scacchi perché gli scacchi perché
gli scacchi dalla loro trasposizione in
virtuale
diciamo solo un gioco che sta attraendo
moltissimi interessi sia da parte della
community dei videogiocatori amatoriali
che ti quelli pro e dei tanti
investitori che stanno investendo sugli
scacchi ho portato in virtuale o portare
sempre gli scacchi per allontanarvi un
po dalla facile associazione di pensiero
tale per cui giocare videogiochi vuol
dire giocare alla playstation e giochi
di calcio o ai giochi di basket non è
così quelli ne sono ne sono una parte ma
non sono una parte diciamo assoluta
questo per dirvi anche che ci troviamo
di fronte quando parliamo di sforza a un
universo veramente fluido
un universo in continua metamorfosi
mentre noi siamo qui il settore degli
sport cambia perché è così nella sua
nelle sue caratteristiche e cambia anche
perché cambiano i trend commerciali e
ludici che spostano un po le attenzioni
da parte delle community e condizionano
le scelte da parte dei grandi player che
sono player d'industria che sono player
relativi al mondo dei broadcasting delle
grandi jorge internazionali perché mi
interessa la dimensione sociale porta un
po un esempio che possa risolvere questa
domanda che un po una provocazione un
grido d'allarme che io che io lancio
riportando un po ad esempio sulla mia
figura non tanto per portarvi luce come
dicevo prima
semplicemente perché nelle diverse
cariche che io ricopro nella mia vita
professionale
una di queste due di queste ecco
immaginate chi vi sta parlando è il
membro di un comitato tecnico
scientifico di un'avventura federazione
degli sport virtuali così come
annunciato dal coni così come presidente
e fondatore di una società ea a capo di
una divisione interamente dedicata a
diffusione della cultura degli sforzi
nel mercato italiano perché vi dico
questo perché nelle moltissime stanze in
cui io mi trovo ad operare sia
ricoprendo dei ruoli consultivi ossia
attraverso delle mansioni un po più
operative
io mai e sottolineo mai sento parlare di
avvicinare i giovani attraverso ai
valori della socialità attraverso gli
sport ma sempre sempre continuamente
sento parlare di sfruttarli attraverso
degli espedienti furbi considerando gli
diciamo meri numeri da convogliare a
delle dinamiche di acquisto commerciale
del prodotto risposte dei suoi annessi e
connessi
vorrei vr voglio un attimo inasprire no
quella che è stata la mia provocazione
facendovi un po immagina non solo
immaginare ma anche toccare con mano
quella che la polverosità di questo
mondo benché io non sia propriamente un
analista però il retaggio del mio
vecchio lavoro da distributore
cinematografico ossessionato lunedì
mattina dal cinetel e quindi senza
spiegarvi troppo i perché ei percome
viva da illustrare di come questo il
settore degli sport sia un settore
destinato a raggiungere il miliardo e
mezzo di dollari di fatturato entro il
così come a farla da padrone dal punto
di vista del target sono i millenni
hansen sony grandissimi protagonisti
indiscussi questo biennio 2020 21 così
come per portare la lente per spostare
la lente sul territorio italiano
le ultime più attendibili ricerche di
mercato ed autorevoli attestano che la
popolazione italiana se ne sta
interessando per il 12 per cento della
popolazione quindi stiamo parlando di 6
milioni di abitanti
abbiamo visto le diverse dimensioni da
di ballo ma chi si sta occupando della
dimensione sociale delle grandissime
opportunità dell'abbattimento delle
barriere di comunicazione relazionali e
delle diversità
ovviamente della diversità di genere chi
si sta occupando di fornire attraverso
gli sport dei modelli in grado di
ispirare le giovani generazioni beh
anche in questo caso vi dico che
un'altra strada è possibile una strada
che ha un sentire un po protetto che ci
restituisce una dimensione più umana una
dimensione percorribile degli sport che
sono un qualcosa di grandioso di
poderoso talmente sono più poderoso di
quanto ne mai nessuna casa di sviluppo o
software house come dicono quelli bravi
saranno mai in grado di realizzarla così
come l'ho vissuta io sulla mia pelle
ed è qui che volevo cominciare a
raccontarvi una storia una storia il cui
protagonista per motivi di riservatezza
prenderà lo pseudonimo di kay di ed è
una storia che nasce dalla mia dalla mia
ingenuità e poi mi esplode piano piano
dentro al cuore divenendo una delle
delle esperienze più gratificanti più
intense più emozionanti della della mia
vita
dopo questa perché questa questa c'è
stata questa nel frattempo è bene il
tutto
il tutto nasce un po da all'interno
delle dinamiche di una nostra consulenza
che abbiamo offerto a una cooperativa
laziale di tipo a e b
del territorio laziale che si era
rivolta a noi per cercare di dare un
nuovo impulso creativo ai suoi progetti
speciali di carattere sportivo e
ricreativo
io al tempo diciamo tutto risale
immaginata d'agosto del 2018
ero il presidente di questa neonata
realtà che non è che avesse chissà quale
portafoglio clienti o quali esperienze
da raccontare per tra virgolette
prendere il lavoro quindi ero andato lì
semplicemente armato delle mie idee ed
ero nella speranza ero desideroso di
stupire in interlocutori con un colpo
geniale questo colpo geniale poi
parlando parlando mumble mumble diciamo
è arrivato anche complice l'aver captata
diciamo una esigenza manifesta da parte
di quella all'interno di quel dialogo
una l'esigenza nasceva dal fatto che
all'interno di quelli sti d'istituto
all'interno del quale operava la
cooperativa con i propri servizi
migliorativi erano stati riscontrati nel
precedente anno scolastico
tantissimi best ovvero bisogni educativi
speciali questi bisogni educativi
speciali non trovavano però riscontro
nelle schede parametrate dagli operatori
sociali che dovranno gestire questi
ragazzi in qualità di assistenti anche
il colpo il colpo di genio
il rombo con una domanda avete mai
sentito parlare degli sport guarda un po
perplesso
gli avevo di fronte la presidentessa
della cooperativa e irresponsabile alla
formazione allora io incalzo e cerco di
di sovrastare prendere in mano le reti
nel discorso con un entusiasmo un po
persuasivo e nel frattempo cerco di
sciorinare la nostra visione degli
sforzi del proprio valore aggiunto
all'interno calata su un contesto
scolastico
nel giro di 15 minuti avevamo stilato 10
punti importantissimi di un progetto che
tuttora il progetto più gratificante
della mia esperienza con con questa
società che puntava tutto semplicemente
su una su una concezione a partire dalla
destrutturazione dell'acronimo best che
è divenuto da bisogni educativi speciali
a basta essere sportivi ribaltare un po
la logica di cattedra in maniera
positiva quindi consentire agli alunni
di prendere il posto dei propri docenti
che a loro volta non diventati i
discenti per apprendere da
dai loro stessi alunni la cultura degli
sport e dei videogiochi in generale
alunni che nel frattempo a loro volta
stavano approfondendo grazie anche un
percorso didattico parallelo quelle che
erano varie sfumature e la ricchezza
culturale del mondo degli sport utile
anche in ottica di collocamento futuro
nel mondo del lavoro
ora non starò qui veramente a
raccontarvi dei sei mesi 8 in cui
abbiamo operato all'interno
dell'istituto e di quanto sia stata
gratificante l'esperienza dal punto di
vista dei risultati ottenuti e dell'aver
convertito quelli che erano gli
scetticismi iniziali dei docenti
immaginatevi anche anche comprensibili
ma voglio proiettarvi direttamente ma
voglio proiettarvi direttamente in una
giornata di aprile metà aprile in cui
complice forse una bici nazione una
festività pasquale un ponte patronale
questo non non lo ricordo ci siamo
ritrovati ad operare in una delle
classiche lezioni solamente con cinque
alunni in classe al che noi avevamo
confidenza con gran parte degli alunni
seppure eravamo su diverse classi si
fidavano a lasciarci comunque soli e 15
distribuiamo io i miei tre soci sui
diversi gruppi classi di lavoro in
particolar modo io mi metto
all'angoletto altezza della cattedra
vicino alla finestra insieme a kay di e
cominciamo da soli ad addentrarci nel
nostro confronto che fossero cinque
minuti mezz'ora adesso non ricordo bene
però ci siamo subito addentrati e che
linea diciamo subito portato nel suo
ragionamento con linguaggio forbito con
un certo fermento creativo lamentando
dal canto suo che i suoi colleghi
avevano indirizzato il lavoro da un
punto di vista troppo concentrato su
questioni di gameplay quando piuttosto
avrebbero dovuto concentrarci su quelle
che a suo avviso erano stati gli
elementi innovativi del gioco gta tra la
terza e la quarta edizione ovvero le
innovazioni da dire alla texture e le
innovazioni relative al mondo narrativo
dello story telling che avevano
decretato veramente la svolta del gioco
decretandone il successo sia dal punto
di vista commerciale che dal punto di
vista della del gradimento da parte
della
gli appassionati era veramente assorto e
colpito da questo suo ragionamento che
aveva anche incalzato attivando un
stimolanti simo parallelismo tra quella
che era l'industria del videogaming
industry messa in parallelo con la
l'industria della cinematografia della
discografia internazionale
quello è stato il colpo di grazia che mi
ha fatto veramente prendere coraggio ha
detto in barba al team building alla
coralità di opinioni ha detto potevano
menia scuola invece di starsene a casa
abbiamo stravolto la scaletta abbiamo
riscritto tutto il corpus del progetto
nel giro di quell'ora e mezza
eravamo totalmente soddisfatti che
eravamo pronti a morire per convincere i
suoi colleghi che avremmo dovuto
perseguire
ormai quella linea discorso tempo io
sentivo mi sentivo un po osservato
un'impressione errata
tant'è che nel frattempo era rientrata
assistente ylenia che mi invita carlo
continua la seguo la faccia molto breve
con tutto il mio stupore io prendo da da
ilenia che che è che vi è un ragazzo
autistico è un ragazzo che ha grandi
difficoltà relazionali che difficilmente
parla con persone che non sono persone
della sua sfera familiare o di grande
confidenza ma al tempo stesso io vorrei
farvi capire che quello stesso che i di
è la stessa persona che proiettata ad un
mese e mezzo di distanza me lo sono
ritrovato con questo puntatore alla mano
strappato da un suo collega a discutere
il project work dal titolo chi deride
edizione della texture il caso gta
davanti a una platea come la nostra
semisconosciuti in cui c'erano alunni di
altre classi ospiti nel frattempo
invitati alla giornata finale del
dell'evento e dopo aver presentato e
dato il giusto tributo a tutti i suoi
compagni di classe a ha presentato il
progetto a partire dalla domanda di
ricerca che aveva mosso tutto
l'intero elaborato fino alla sua
soddisfazione scientifica con tanto di
citazioni bibliografiche o così questa
che legge della mie spalle è l'unica
frase che chiedi ha rilasciato
all'interno del suo forum di valutazione
in cui ovviamente dovrò valutare
l'operato della sua assistente annuale e
al che mi viene da dire
forse la domanda più più importante
delle tante che che ho toppato fino
adesso ma non staremo forse sbagliando
qualcosa
dico ciò è proprio tra soprattutto
questo in relazione agli sforza questo
mondo che vi ho raccontato po alla
lontana oggi tra le lotte di potere per
prendere lo scettro mettersi la corona e
siederà al trono di una cura federazione
tra le associazioni di categoria che
reclamano di essere quelle più
autorevoli di essere appunto degne di
questo nome
tra chi si mette in fila e cerca un
posto per essere hanno annoverato tra le
50 all e 670 mila persone degne di
essere menzionate come le più autorevoli
e influenti del mondo degli sport tra
altre jorge che si quotano in borsa
fuori nel mondo reale anche sotto i
nostri occhi
nel posto più più sicuro e nel posto in
cui tutti noi dobbiamo credere che debba
passare l'istruzione l'istruzione e la
formazione delle generazioni che e lo
dico senza mezzi termini è la scuola
pubblica ci sono tantissimi gay di che
attendono solamente di incrociare uno
sguardo gentile attendono solamente di
essere ascoltati ed dà voce a tutto ciò
che hanno da esprimere dentro
sottoponendogli una giusta base di i
contenuti e gli argomenti fiducia
empatia in barba pregiudizi a burocrazie
a strategie commerciali e lotte di
potere grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]